- [Narrator] JaQuel Knight
is the creative mind
many of Beyoncé's iconic performances.
He's worked with her for years
and he's been dancing his entire life.
- I remember dancing in my
grandmother's living room
at the age of four and five,
copying the things I saw on TV.
As I got older I remember copying all the
major iconic MTV award shows,
performances, Soul Train performances.
And then when I was 16
I started my own dance group
with my best friend in Atlanta
and that was kind of
the first serious step
towards choreography
and creative direction.
- [Narrator] At just 18,
JaQuel landed a gig choreographing
- One of the best videos of all time.
- [Narrator] Single Ladies.
- [JaQuel] Frank Gatson Junior,
who was choreographer
and creative director
for Beyoncé and Destiny's Child for,
you know, ages.
He was actually working on
Michelle Williams' debut project.
In the process of that he was like,
"Wow, you know how to teach,
you know how to deal with people,
you lead really well,
you know, how bout you
come on board and help
choreograph the video with us."
And the next week he was like,
"Can you come choreograph
the entire promo tour?"
And then a few months went by,
he called and was like,
"Yo, I have this Beyoncé record,
can you fly to New York tonight?"
I was like, "Yo, I just got the call!
Going to New York tonight! Yoncé!"
(laughs)
Got to New York,
the record was Single Ladies.
Once getting in the space with her,
starting to dance with her,
and see how she thinks and move
through the project and how she
see things in her head,
I was completely blown away.
- [Narrator] Ten years later,
JaQuel and Beyoncé teamed up
for yet another iconic performance.
They incorporated homecoming
moves made popular by
Historically Black
Colleges and Universities.
- [JaQuel] You know, that
was a thing that Beyoncé
kinda woke up with one day and was like,
"Yo, let's do this homecoming experience."
The research behind it,
we went back and watched football games.
You watch homecomings,
so many probates.
We watched fraternities in the club,
we watched sororities.
We watched a load of just
black college experiences
and then kind of got in the mindset
of creating the right energy.
I wish I could count the hours
that went into it but we worked
for like five to six months on it.
Working with B during the
rehearsal process is like,
it's kind of a out of body experience.
People don't understand
the amount of effort.
Her work ethic is out of this world.
And it's never just one thing.
When we're creating choreography it's
okay boom, where's wardrobe at?
Bring them in so they can see
what the choreography is.
Okay, boom.
Where are we on the stage?
Let's make sure lighting knows
how to light this.
Boom, where are the cameras?
Okay let's look at this camera
and then do this.
We're always thinking of every
single piece of the puzzle.
So just to see that her mind
understands every part of
putting a show together
and she remembers and
she knows all of her marks
and she knows all of her lyrics
and how she's gonna sing everything.
She's really in there getting it,
asking questions.
You doing it a hundred times.
So we spend a lot of
time in the dance studio
making sure that these things come off
feeling like nothing.